hello everyone
a very warm good evening good morning or
good afternoon in whichever part of the
world you are
and we hope you all are doing great we
are delighted to have you all today with
us to get you all started with an
extensive training to work on your
independent research project
today we are meeting to talk about the
research uh internship or the fellowship
program
so to talk about the program it has been
designed to help young researchers and
students take the advantage of the
bioinformatics resources for analysis of
complex life science data and become
versed in bioinformatics
the research fellows being a part of the
fellowship program participate in
[ __ ] edge bioinformatics research led
by expert mentors
the internship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mentor guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a bioinformatics project
the platform is a cloud-based analytical
server used by research labs and
independent scientists around the world
i would like to introduce myself first
of all my name is ali curry
community manager i am responsible for
daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of a community
that is managed by pine biotech
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 15 000 users around
the world and due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine the local program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
so i would now like to take this
opportunity to introduce our company and
and the team for the very first time to
those who are joining us
let me introduce uh as our company first
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the omissive research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
the omis logic programs follow a
project-based learning approach using a
research grade tools to analyze data
from top peer reviewed journals the
training has been completed by over 15
000 participants from 162 countries and
over 300 workshops for six different
specialization tracks which include
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omics data analysis
as a result we have acquired
professional certification to offer our
curriculum and support research projects
using our omixlogic project based
curriculum and over the past several
years we have had the privilege of
working with a number of organizations
developing a training program for
research oriented students faculty and
democratizing bioinformatics making this
discipline accessible to thousands of
students and faculty around the world
i am honored to introduce the founders
and the team members of the company
dr alfred tober who comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of his major
projects is the establishment of the
double bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr donatbrotsky is the director of
double bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of artwork by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right julia panoff is an expert
bioinformatician
abby tatovsky leads the development of
the tea bioinfo platform
dr harpreet has an expertise in the
application of statistical machine
learning techniques on biomedical data
dr mohit mazumgar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and he has been developing
collaborations with universities as a
mentor and project lead for our mixed
logic training and research fellowship
dr raghavan lakshmi
is an accomplished computational
biologist with an experience in
large-scale analysis of multi-omics data
and data science methods in precision
oncology and protein dna structural
bioinformatics so now to talk about the
research fellowship program
a question that comes to my mind i often
think with so much data available on any
biological topic and question running an
independent in silico research project
over the
winters seems like a great opportunity
but do you have the resources to
complete your big data analysis
do you have a mentor that can help match
the right analysis method to the
research question do you have a
community to keep you accountable and
provide you with the feedback
and if your answer to these questions is
a no but you are motivated to get
something done before me we are offering
a special program that is the only logic
research fellowship or the internship
program and we are here to talk about
the very same thing
so let's first of all get started by
signing up on the learn.org logic portal
this educational portal will help you
get started on your bioinformatics
journey
as a part of this
signing up on the portal you will get
the access to the omixlogic courses and
also to the programs
you can also explore various example
projects by research fellows in various
fields including neurosciences genomics
transcriptomics infectious diseases
metabolic disorders agriculture etc
throughout the course you will be given
directions to access the tea bioinfo
platform for bioinformatics processing
and analysis of transactomics data the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and analysis cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
pipelines different stages of analysis
would be performed in different sections
of this multi-omics platform
so now let's quickly get to
learn.ormixlogic portal and sign up
so that we have the access to the
resources and follow with the mentors
let me
re-share my screen
here is the link
thank you so much ojasi for sharing the
link
you can find the link to the
learn.ormislogic portal in the chat box
so once you are up there on the portal
you need to click on the login button to
sign up
on the portal and create your account
and get started with multi or mix
training
either you can create an account for
yourself by putting in your details
which will include an email id password
uh your details and also you can sign up
using any of the social media platforms
i will be signing up by using my gmail
account
so those who have already completed
their sign up can please put a yes or
one in the chat box
that i know uh who all have already
signed up and those who have not signed
up yet please follow the link that
ojasmi has shared in the chat box and
make sure that you are signed up
because today we'll be talking about the
resources on the amis logic learn portal
itself and it will be easy for you to go
through them and explore the platform if
you are signed up
uh thank you vishal upindirashna and
kiti for
the response
i'll be waiting for the response by
others as well
please make sure that you complete your
sign up and put a yes or one in the chat
box
[Music]
i can see a lot of you who are signing
up
now those who have completed their sign
up the next step for them is
to complete their profile
now i'm just going to briefly explain
what a complete profile looks like
so you must make sure that you have a
profile picture
it should be a zoomed in picture
your name should be in title case that
is your um
the first alphabet should be capital and
the other should be small please make
sure that it is not in small letters or
capitalized because this is the same
format that will reflect on your
certificate after you complete a
particular course
also please make sure that you have
connected your social media accounts and
add a brief file about yourself that
could include your educational
background and also your research
interest
with specialization field you would like
to work in or are currently working
so for every course work that you pick
and go through you will be able to
monitor your progress here on your
profile itself and for the courseworks
that you complete you can see your
certificate here download it and also
share with the world
for every course that you complete you
will be getting some points for it and
you can see your progress and your
points or your achievements here in your
profile tab itself
today we will talk we will be talking
about these courses in more detail and
how
uh this whole program is structured
around these courses and then how you
can work on your research project
so now to discuss about the program
structure
and also
i would like you all to meet our mentors
for the research internship program so
for that i would now like to welcome our
mentor dr raghavedran who will be
introducing himself so over to you dr
raghavendran
thank you very much sonalika and it's
very very nice to see
so many people and very uh
enthusiastic uh participation also let
me find ways to share my screen and let
me make the
make my zoom talk to my powerpoint
okay can you all see my screen i think
not yet
my zoom is still trying to find trying
to find ways to see this okay
now i think it should work
can you see my screen
yes so we can see yourself okay i think
you can see my screen yeah i also got
this uh
so welcome everybody one more time and
uh i am raghavendra i am a research
consultant and mentor with fine biotech
and omix logic and i am going to be your
mentor for your research fellowship
program uh this
um
for this session yeah okay thank you
i'm sorry about that i'm going to open
my powerpoint again it just crashed
in my 4.3d
okay i think now it is working
sorry about that it always happens most
of the time even though i set up
multiple times
before okay i think you can see my
screen now
and i hope it doesn't fail
thank you very much and welcome one more
time yeah and i'm raghaveen i'm a
research consultant and mentor with bind
biotech and omix logic and i am going to
be your mentor for your research
fellowship program uh with omix logic so
i am trained in bioinformatics and i
hold a computational biology from max
bank institute germany and my broad
research interest focuses on
using and applying data science
techniques such as machine learning
deep learning applied to integration of
multi-omics data like gene mutation
and um
gene variant transcriptomic variation
and epigenetic variation etcetera
etcetera so
my role in find biotech as i already
mentioned includes developing curricular
and mentoring students like you for
which i am extremely uh
excited to
interact with you all so let me go
through
some of the brief introductions
of my career so far so uh nothing fancy
so i studied uh or i'm a basically
computational biologist and
bioinformatics by training so which
covers most of this black and purple
circle in this huge systems biology
network so i did my computational
biology in max planck institute where i
tried to build a uh software for
automation of nmr spectra data analysis
and through which i understood a lot of
bioinformatics of bioinformatics and
structural biology of protein sequences
and then from that a natural progression
i went and joined a genomics data in a
genomics lab in
institute of bioinformatics and applied
biotechnology in bengaluru where i
developed multiple methods for
automating a pipeline for ngs data
analysis for plants and also for
patients and also for
most models
that they had so from there my interest
shifted towards big data and then
shifted towards
data-driven approaches like using
machine learning and using multi-omics
data
applying machine learnings and ai
methods on multi-amix data where i take
the raw sequence data or raw ngs
high throughput sequencing data and
convert that information into um
structured data and then fro from which
machine learning can learn
the underlying
relationships between these uh
structured data to identify or to help
us classify or help us identify
patterns within the subjects that we are
providing it so far that's a very brief
overview of
what i had in my
career so far so my broad interest lies
in cancer genomics and understanding a
different biology of cancer through
machine learning methods and through
data science methods
in such since i'm also interested in
working in
ngs sequencing methods so
my interest and your research areas and
or the search focus will uh coincide
very nicely and i will be extreme i am
extremely um
interested to
interact with each and every one of you
during your course of a
training ship or during those course of
internship with omix logic that's a very
brief introduction about myself and
i will now pass the stage back on to
sonalika
for further
explanation and further detailing about
the research uh
internship
program that you are going to be uh
signing up with and
in general for in general if you have
any other queries you can also contact
us and yeah over over to you
thank you so much dr raghav indian i
would now like to invite dr
priya
to please introduce herself and we would
then be going uh proceeding further to
talk about the program structure of the
research internship program so over to
you dr priya
yeah hello everyone i am dr priya opal
i am a omix logic trainer and project
mentor at uh
omix logic learn platform so regarding
my educational background i did my post
doctorate from indian institute of
science bangalore in molecular biology
and bioinformatics regarding my phd
so my specialization was in life
sciences uh particularly in stress
physiology and i did this from guru
nanak dev university amritsar india
regarding my master's and bachelor's
again i did this from gndu amritsar i
have 25 publications so far which are
published in journals of national and
international review
next slide
yeah so regarding my post-doctorate
project work i worked on identification
and functional characterization of
various transcription factors involved
in secondary metabolism and dathura
mutual using molecular biology studies
so here i
purified the transcription factors and
then we worked on
basically on mip transcription factor
and its interaction with dna so uh we
use various uh maybe cd spectra and
maybe some other approaches and some
bioinformatics approaches to conclude
this project and then second project was
on cloning characterization and
applications of transition factors from
a biotechnology important microbe
towards metabolic engineering of a
target compound
so this was basically a secondary
metabolism related project
regarding my phd i worked on brussels
asteroid a regulated anti-oxidative
defense system of drastic agency under
heavy metal stress so this was basically
a plant stress physiology based work
regarding my masters
my specialization was in biotechnology i
worked on biochemical changes associated
with seed development and vidhanas
omnifera and i received a young
scientist award for this project work
regarding my project work at omix logic
i worked on reversal of tachrolimus and
serolomous induced adverse effects
during organ transplantation using
transcriptomic approaches
next slide is america
so regarding my industry background i've
worked as a senior bioinformatician at
the gene box mumbai india i've also
worked as a scientist at eid parry
bangalore and my research interest lies
in cancer biology next generation
sequencing data science stress
physiology and drug discovery and
repurposing
so it's really
very nice to see you all here and
looking forward to interact with you all
thank you over to you soon
thank you so much dr priya it was very
nice to listen to both of our mentors dr
raghavensen and dr priya i would now
like to pass on this session to dr mohit
to enlighten us uh with the structure of
the research internship program and also
then we'll be taking up further
questions by everyone present here over
to you doctor mohit
thank you soon am i audible
yes sir you are audible and we can also
yes
we can see you but we can't see your
screen yet
yeah hello everyone it's it's really
nice to see you all and thank you for
taking out time to
join the session and uh we would be like
we would also like to interact with you
so please post your questions um as
popender has already posted
his questions or similarly if you guys
have any questions that you want
answer uh uh from then please let us
know because this is an interactive
session and we would like to help you
all like address the questions that you
have and
that would help you understand what we
are doing and also what you can do
collaborating with us
meanwhile you post your questions
i'll share my string
and
i will also
show you that what we have planned so
far and
what we are going to start in february
starting uh
first week
just a second please
so my screen is visible now to all of
you
yes sir
all right so what we would wanted to
discuss with you is also about uh the
program that is being piloted in every
university but it is also available
online to all of you
uh who are not from mit university but
from different universities across the
globe
so this research fellowship program is
is an amazing program because it is to
help
students develop research projects and
these research projects are not
something that we are
doing as a reputation of any project but
it is a noble project and that is quite
a challenge for anyone who is starting
with their research journey to start and
do something new
it's kind of challenging for researchers
it's kind of challenging for faculty so
we
kind of uh did
we will be presenting to you today that
how we did simplify all of it and made
it possible for anyone anyone to learn
and then
work on real data sets work on real
project and come up with really
great outcomes
some of the areas that we are focusing
right now is as you could see listed
on the left side of the
slide
so we are working on uh research areas
which are really cutting edge and
is the need of industry and where the
industry is working on where the
research labs are working on where the
entire research communities are working
to help
address some of the pressing challenges
of the 21st century
so that would be to work on precision
medicine that is to find personalized
medicine to find answers to the
questions that we don't know the answers
of yet so finding cure
or finding drugs or finding you know
information and insight from the data
that could help in drug development that
could help in
personalized treatment uh patient
selection and all of that
and then uh you've got to learn about
you know many of you know about
infectious diseases so anything that
causes an infection
could be
placed in under infectious diseases
basically
diseases that caused by microorganisms
small microorganisms could be bacteria
could be virus could it be other
pathogens
and then
to help with
the neurodegenerative diseases or the
diseases that you
learn about that is associated with
neuroscience
and then we have a really new area of
research which is based o mix
uh so omix as you many of you might know
about and might not know about
omix data
omics is a
kind of technology that helps us
to generate
very specific and very high quality
and in depth data that information
is something that is changing biology
because
what we are getting with thomix data is
detailed information very detailed
information about
all the genes that we have all the dna
content that we have all the expression
expression of proteins that we
get from a particular time point and uh
all the changes that epigenomic changes
the methylation and all due to which
there is a difference in the way we are
from we can you know
we can say that i'm different from all
of you you're different from each other
so how that is possible that is
possible through those
minor changes that happens in our genome
and epigenetic factors does play a role
in that
then the application of genomics and all
this mixed technology not into just
space research where astronauts health
is one of the key thing other than that
it is also to
get sustainability in you know food
production
uh how do we do it
in a way that could address the
huge problem of uh
of getting
uh right kind of uh
food and right kind of um
agricultural advancements that could
help us address the issue with the
you know poverty and all of that and
then how all of this could make sense
for ai
for drug discovery and how do we apply
how ai is applied and how machine
learning deep learning and
data science is being applied to all of
this type of data so that
we gained the insights from this so why
we use uh you know machine learning deep
learning and data science now and not
before because many of us thinks
bioinformatics to be
about you know finding uh doing drug
discovery many things that
bioinformatics is uh doing uh you know
um
developing tools doing programming
but it is more than that it has it has
changed over the years and it is
evolving really fast and rapidly so i
believe that
all of us should be a bit aware of this
because what we are talking about is
about human health about our own health
about our own well-being so this is kind
of very important in that sense not just
for education not just for a career but
also for ourselves our health and
everything associated with that
so this uh that's why it becomes very
important and
it could be like challenging it is kind
of challenging when we started and then
i'm talking about myself i have a phd in
computational biology i i worked in some
of the top institutes around the globe
uh including in india
and have been collaborated with
collaborated with over 50 to 80
scientists all around the globe and
completed almost 100 projects
and published
more than 50 articles so i've gone
through this and i have uh understood
the kind of challenges that one would
face when they start with this and they
do the research and it's really a
challenge it could be really challenging
so to simplify that and to help a larger
community of students like group of
students or individual student we have
prepared all the things that we are
going to showcase to you today and how
this can be used by anyone without
without the knowledge of you know coding
without the knowledge of some of the
basics because we prepared all of that
in one place
so we have uh as you have already met dr
priya dr raghav uh myself and uh ilya is
also one of the mentors uh who is our
ceo and has been he has been helping a
lot of uh big data projects uh uh in the
in uh using the his in
his industry expertise as well as a
multi-comics integration using the
tbi info platform
uh so from mit we have a few faculties
who have
designed some of the projects that we
will be working on in collaboration with
the faculty where students have an
opportunity students from amity
university have an opportunity to join
these projects these will be really
high value projects because
we are looking for translational outcome
and also commercialization aspects so we
will be
really
helping
the students to
gain that skill sets to be able to work
on high value projects that will be
that could be defining for their career
now uh about what we are doing so we are
closing the gap for research and
discovery this is very important because
there's a huge gap because it requires
skill sets then you need to have the
right kind of tools to do this and then
you need to understand what is the
application so when you google or when
you go online many things that it is
it's kind of simple it is simple if you
if you have
experience of maybe 15 20 years and you
know where to find what because every
day you will find that new publications
are coming out a new method is being
published
and when you start doing research you'll
find like hundreds of tools available
online that one could leverage to do
certain things but what does what is the
right path
that is something very difficult to you
know figure out and when you do a phd
when you work for five six years on a
one problem then you
get to know okay after testing so many
things
after doing all that you know hard work
by trying out different things by
uh by
exploring different data sets and then
looking for information reading through
literature you get to know about
some of the areas where this could be
applied now what is difference what
difference do we make is that we build
this pathway
to guide students to guide researchers
to guide faculty and also to guide uh
anyone who wishes to learn this which is
to apply this and who wishes to uh you
know publish or who is just to showcase
uh what they have achieved because those
are some of the things that are really
important to grow in our career and also
to showcase um and to the community that
what we have done and why we bring value
to any organization that we are working
with
so um it's kind of simple the way it is
uh designed
so why would uh i say that it is simple
when it is so complex because uh we try
to simplify things and that's one of our
company's motto is to simplify
bioinformatics and made it accessible to
all the students that are joining our
programs who are joining these research
internships where we are providing
with all these materials coursework that
is available online anyone can do it uh
at their uh
at any time so there's a left there's a
benefit of doing online course work is
that you are not bound to just do it
at a specific given time but you'll have
a lot of time throughout the day where
you can just you know go to the portal
and
learn
in a step-wise manner and one of the
things that we have done in
these
courses that were put together and you
can see that here that it starts from
introduction to bioinformatics so we
have basic coursework that sonalika
explained and that basic coursework
enables any biologist
any clinician or any person who's doing
you know not not bioinformatics but
from other fields to learn about what
bioinformatics are data sciences and how
does
how this is being applied to these
different new areas of research so
genomics it's been used for a while for
maybe last 20 years but it has come out
uh as one of the
brightest field because it do tell us
about um the entire dna content and
there are huge sequencing projects where
we are trying to
understand what would be the genomic
composition of different plants
different herbs that has medicinal
abilities qualities
from different
microorganisms
where we are trying to learn about that
what these microorganisms do how they
the genes are and why they cause some
havoc such as that what you've seen
with kobe 19 and coronavirus so
finding answers is something that we all
as a human being are curious about we
are always looking for answers and those
answers gives us i mean that
inquisitness is is really what drives
humanity to the next level and
we think that if we all can contribute a
little bit towards this
[Music]
a big reason then it would be worth
worth a while so
talking about these different
technologies what we do is that we start
with for people who
who are
from a different background from for
example computer sciences many many from
the art background also join because
they are also inquisite and they also
want to learn and they also want to
discover new things that discovery is is
is not so simple as you know scientists
are doing and writing grants and
like trying their level best to do
discovery and that's what we are
bringing to
students at a student level to be able
to do discovery and how do you do
discovery it is data-driven discovery
that we have talking about we are not
talking about doing wet lab experiments
but the data that is being generated
from the pet lab experiments the huge
data is being generated every day
what has changed in last five years or
ten years is that the way data is being
generated because it's now high
throughput now doing experiments is
really easy because it's automated
because the technology has changed and
technology has has advanced so now we
are generating data
in terabytes in megabytes uh may that
the social media data may not be any
data like you you're
wearing you know if you're
having those smart watches wearing the
smart watches it it records your
heartbeat it records your um oxygen
levels and all of that that is
that is important data because if you
think about that and correlate with you
know other genetic factors you might
find new things so there's an
opportunity to find new things now
because this data is available online on
public repositories because
because many of the
researchers and many of the research
grants and all of that depends on
that information to be uh out public and
that's that's really a good place to
start with the discovery process so
what we do is that we train you with
about with the initial training if
you're not trained on these data types
we train you on genomics metagenomics
and omix data not only on omix data but
also how to interpret this data also
structural data so all sort of
structural data clinical data you you
name it like anything related to health
care anything related to biology is now
bioinformatics and data science so it's
just not bioinformatics that if you're
doing a degree in bioinformatics then
this is the program for you but it is a
program for anyone who is working on the
biological aspects who's working on
health care who's working on
you know agriculture and all of that
so
then
some of the things that you need to do
when we talk about publications when we
talk about
different type of
visualization presentation reporting you
need to do some downstream analysis some
uh some information that can be
extracted through these programming
languages such as python and r so python
and r so we have basic tutorials that
anyone can learn from and those are
available uh as a part of coursework
that would be
that would that everyone will get who
joins this research fellowship program
where you will learn about where to
apply bioinformat r and python in
bioinformatics so it is not a dedicated
programming
um
coursework but it is to apply python nr
for data analysis so that is the basic
introduction which usually takes um two
weeks to one month where you go through
this basic training
and
you
learn about all of this what is the
purpose of learning this learning the
purpose of is to apply this so this is
where we are different from many other
companies because we are working on
project based uh curriculum project
based outcomes so this project-based
learning is to be able to work on real
data as i said now
working on data sets
so we also have put together a lot of
example projects these example projects
uh varies from
latest technologies such as single cell
rna technologies speech spatial genomics
and spatial transcriptomics to uh very
basics of you know stars go to genomics
so you will learn about coronavirus and
all of its genome and how to do that
genomic analysis to like agricultural uh
projects such as protect or drought
resistance so looking at
gene expression so this technology could
be applied to different kind of uh
example a different kind of problems and
it is not just
about these six fields that i discussed
about but we are capable of uh
any data that is publicly available
which is the entire ncbi geo entire ncbi
sra so if you don't know about ncbi ncbi
is a big big
repository or it has a group of
repositories where this data is publicly
available so you pick any data set and
you want to analyze that data set for
certain aspect we will be able to do
that
so that varies from you know cancer
research because there's a lot of
research ongoing with cancer and there's
a lot of information and data sets are
available for that so one of the
objective is to get information from
sequences sequence level
and then go to the structural level so
from two dimensional data from single
dimension two dimensional data to
three-dimensional data
that is the entire drug discovery
portfolio if you could say
starting from a sequence where you're
finding information and then building a
three-dimensional structure and then
finding chemi informatics like then you
are applying chemistry all that is
possible through this
this training
and research fellowship program
now uh once you have learned about this
technology and here what you're doing is
that in the last slide what you're doing
is that you're going through these
project examples which we have put
together as courses uh project courses
and
one of the biggest advantages of doing
it it on learn online is that we have
simplified it so that
anyone can do this analysis and one of
the reasons we are using the topper
brand from this research platform is
that it is no good it has a no code
bioinformatics way of dealing dealing
with things so people who do not
who do not have a background in coding
and would want to do the analysis can do
it without any knowledge of coding but
yes as you gradually learn about all of
this you get you get interest and like
doing more that's where coding comes in
and that's where you can choose if you
want to do coding or not so these are
projects that one can take
to learn about how it is done how it is
done for these different examples and
then what could be done for different uh
new things so this gives us an idea how
to deal with it and what can be done so
this is an important part this is step
two step one is where you learned about
the technology step one is where you
have learned about the
introduction from the very basic then
you move to different types of omics
data whichever
excites you the most you can choose a
track and then you can move on that
track if it is infectious diseases if it
is cancer if it is you know metabolic
disorders any disease
that you are interested in or any um any
project that you're interested in so you
move to that direction so here you get
to do it through the example projects so
that you learn you know how to do it and
what people have already done after that
you start working on something that is
like a research project in itself where
you're trying to find
new answers to a question that have not
been answered that's really the most
exciting part but to get to here you
need to
you need to learn how people have done
it what people have done
there's a literature review there is a
small test that you have to pass to be
able to work on a real research project
now this real research projects are as i
said that uh our mentors are helping
design these research projects dr
raghavendran here uh dr priya here ilya
and all of our team and other mentors
that
we just showed you they are helping
students to work on how they can come up
with a research question and if not we
already have a lot of ongoing projects
we are an international company where we
have collaborators from all around the
globe and we have collaborators from top
universities in the world who are
where the faculties are contributing
they're working on their own research
projects so there's an opportunity to
collaborate and work on those research
projects as well if you don't have your
own research project but you can also
work on your own research project that
is really a great thing i guess
so these are the three steps so very
simple
after you
go through the steps it could be in
three months it could be in six months
you will be able to do what you will be
able to get through this training and
learn about these different types of
data types you will find and you could
find an impactful research topic and the
mentors are obviously
helpful and the mentors are going to
help you guide through that entire
process to find an impactful research
topic and then there's a weekly meeting
that we do where students are presenting
their research
and they get their feedback research
expert feedback and will tell you that
okay this is the way to go so that you
are on the right path and you can do it
in a shorter period of time so one of
the challenges with this sort of
training is
to be able to get it in a shorter period
of time so a phd takes five to six years
this is six months only that is also
challenging for us but we have this
entire structure
we have excellent mentors and we have an
amazing platform to cut short this time
and to get to that level
now
that is the that is the
entire research fellowship
structure now i am going to tell you
about the available projects this is for
mit students they can work on these some
of the projects that have been mentioned
by uh that we have collaborated with
faculty and discussed several or several
meetings and now have uh structured data
sets and structure research questions
that one could uh
one could participate in and it would be
not so difficult because everything will
be guided and also you'll be learning
about the logic it's just not that
we will tell you that do this do this
and do this but why you are doing this
you have to ask that question it's all
question driven it's it that is what is
actually
helpful when you join a company or when
you go to the next level in your career
so you need to ask questions you can't
be like you we are not machines we are
human beings we are capable of asking
questions and that's where this entire
process is to ask questions and find
answers so always ask questions so these
are some of those projects that uh amity
students can work on and collaborate
with us so that we can guide them
through this through this through
different uh
problems that we have defined with amity
faculty
followed by that um
the another opportunity that i wanted to
tell you all about is this research
symposium so it's a free research
symposium for those who will be
participating
it is
for those who would be presenting uh
there is a poster competition and uh
there's a small fee for poster
competition because we have prizes for
second third prizes uh like 10 prizes
for those who are excelling in this uh
that uh that is cash price and also
a lot of other opportunities related to
that because it's also a platform to
collaborate with international
researchers and faculty so this is about
the research fellowship presentation
that i have
now um i would like to show you
in this entire process
which we have
have
on our website
so
some of the web pages
that i would want you to take a look at
first you all have gone through this
first page which is the learn
omixlogic.com
where we have the courses listed out the
courses that i've showed you and also
that courses have a component of
projects
now when you log in here it's a free
login obviously many course work is free
but obviously a mentor guided program
with all of that is isn't is not
possible for make it uh free it is
something that we are doing sustainable
we are providing
uh
these projects and resources which are
really really expensive to the student
community through this research
fellowship program at a very sustainable
price so that anyone who is interested
can do this and we'll be able to do this
and on top of it we are providing
additional scholarships for students so
that they can also from a weaker
financial background so that they can
also join and fulfill and contribute
so that is about that so once you have
registered here you can check out the
courses and uh introduction to
bioinformatics is a free course that
gives you an introduction to these
different uh
areas where bioinformatics is applied
and then the next course is bytes and
molecules this is also like a free
course and obviously when you do a free
course you also get a certification it's
just not that it's a free ghost so
you'll not get anything but you will get
certifications that you can
certification that you can showcase so
whatever i was discussing is described
in much more detail so if you had any
questions you can take these courses and
learn about what i just discussed so may
that be transcriptomics precision
medicine space omex uh r language and
all of that so this is these are free
courses once you complete a free course
you will get an automated subscription
because you have created a login so you
have your own login you have your own
profile this is your profile so this is
your profile you should put a nice
picture of yourself you should tell
about what you are up to and you can
link add your linkedin and all that
research gate or facebook so that people
who are interested in your research can
reach out to you through these pro
through this links
we have a huge community here ten
thousand tens of thousands people so
many recruiters also see this and could
reach out to you for
a job opportunity or an internship
opportunity so having a good profile is
very important now um about this profile
this also shows you the project so once
you complete a project it will showcase
in the project trap so you wanted to see
what projects people have done that is
also that something that you can check
out on this website so you will find
student projects so the students who
have completed this research fellowship
program have been able to submit their
project in on the portal that has all
the information so it's a very detailed
reporting similar report could be
submitted to the university it has an
overview data set abstract introduction
methods results discussion conclusion
references acknowledgement so all that
information is right here if you have
any question that how this can be done
what kind of people have done it so
undergraduates post graduates phd
students and even high school students
been able to do this through this entire
process so it's not so difficult if you
think that it is difficult for you i
would bet that it is not so much
difficult anyone can do this i'm very
much sure about it so that's why i'm
claiming this now if you are starting so
how do you start and go to the next
level this page could be helpful
and i'm gonna share the link so this is
introduction
finding answers learn to do
bioinformatics this is a
first page or maybe this page both of
the pages are same
it's getting started with data science
for biologists now
you do the introduction courses
bioinformatics in our bioinformatics
python if you you want to bytes and
molecules i've already shown you these
are the online coursework that anyone
can do anytime
at their own convenience
after the online courses
you can start you know this is a nice
video that tells all about all of this
recorded by elia brodsky our ceo and
then you will find all the details we
have these university collaborations and
uh also um
academic and industrial collaboration so
famous life sciences pharma academy are
industrial collaborative collaborators
who are providing opportunities for
students for internships and jobs and
except and all those all of that so now
the steps i told you already the steps
using my slide deck but i will again
show you the steps so that every one of
you is
sure and clear about what the steps are
so the step is first step as you already
created a login so the first step is
just to create a login and when you
create a login and do the course work
you get points you get points to
when you complete a kind of a quiz
complete a course and earn a certificate
so basic training is the first step this
introductory introduction to
bioinformatics bytes and molecules not
just three i'd like to it would be great
if you can share this link as i'm going
through the page that would be great or
anyone else please do that
now um these are three courses that one
can start with so
ultimate goal is to be able to work on a
bioinformatics project fit the training
so this is the pro this is the course
that gives you an understanding how to
design a project where these data sets
are where do you find these data sets
online i told you about ncbi i told you
about sra but there are so many other
data sets that
databases sorry where you will find
these data sets that could help you
design a new problem new research that
has never been done before that could be
published
now uh the entire process again
the intermediate coursework will help
you learn about these different
technologies once you do the basic
coursework this is just the basic part
after the basic part you come to the
intermediate part and you gain points
here as you finish and once you reach 10
000 points you are eligible for the
research fellowship
uh if you are starting from
uh you will be eligible for the research
project
so
as i've already told you this is the
intermediate coursework and then you
have the project examples and obviously
there's a certification
and uh after that there's a
qualification exam
that helps you to uh that helps us to
learn about you that which research
project is best suited for you
and then these are the three outcomes
that i've already presented you and
these are the different projects that
students have done so there is also
youtube video that students have
recorded so you can also watch these
videos that are also listed in the next
page so the next page i'm going to show
is the research project topics so the
research project topics let's start with
the form many of you might have filled
up this form if you have not please fill
up this form so please would you do
share this link to all of you or all of
uh all of uh who are participating in
today's webinar so this is the form that
gives us an idea what your research
interest is is and where the what
direction you would want to go to
so we will take some of the entries and
we will discuss those in much more
detail but let me tell you how this
works so we are going to ask you about
your level of education that will help
us design the right kind of material and
projects for you then we are going to
ask you about how long this could be
what how much amount of how much amount
time do you have we also need to know
that every day or in a week how much
time you will have for this that will
also help us uh
know that what could be achieved in that
point of time so these are the
information that we seek from you when
you start the research fellowship
program now we are next going to ask you
what is your level of understanding of
bioinformatics and data science so is it
like a beginner level is it like an
intermediate level or an advanced level
so if you have already worked on some of
these data sets by yourself on or in
some other internship or in your uh
college coursework then
you can choose intermediate in advance
after that we we are going to ask you
about what kind of data analysis
interests you the most so if you have
gone through the bites and molecule
coursework
which is a free coursework you will know
about what is transcriptomic data
analysis what is genomic meta genomic
epigenomic structural and data science
and machine learning so you
based on that could choose
which interests you most so this is a
one this is one that's the one field
that you can choose if you are
interested in multiple of these fields
you can write it in the text box so if
you're interested transcriptomic data
analysis plus data science and machine
learning analysis you can write that out
and henceforth you can add more data
analysis not just these listed here if
there is something more that you know
about we can also help you with that
now after that where you would want to
apply this knowledge you can
which problem that you would want to
solve is it related to the viruses and
protozoans or sorry infectious diseases
and all of that is it like the space
research
that does that interest you more because
nasa is also working with a lot of these
areas and they are depositing a lot of
data sets from the international space
stations
where these microgravity experiments are
going on and also different experiments
are going on nasa gene lab
is a repository where you'll find this
data and also sra and ncbi
so is it spatiomics is it precision
oncology is it neuroscience is it
immunology is it metabolic disorder is
it biotechnology or agriculture so we
are going to ask you about that like
which field would you want to apply this
if you don't know we can also help you
out
when you go through this intermediate
coursework where there are research
projects that we have put together that
will give you a fair amount of idea that
which area that you would be
willing to work on so
the coursework actually helps in
deciding the research area if it is not
clear to you
uh and that is all right if it is not
clear i mean when i started i was not
sure what i was working on and as the
project came i started working on those
uh so that is perfectly fine
if you know what you're working what
you're going to work on that is the best
outcome because you have a direction you
have a goal and you know that this is
the area i want to explore because
maybe
you want to go and join who you would
want to wealth health organization you
want to go and work in the us
under a specific
organization
you want to go work in europe you want
to work in india and help
scientists or with research problems
all of that is your bigger vision to
reach that bigger vision you have to
figure out which organization suits you
the most and if you think about that
organization you can check what research
they are doing what areas they are
working on and then you can design a
research proposal accordingly so in this
box you can tell about tell us about
that that what research title you would
think would work best for you what
research proposal that you would want to
work on and then there's an option to
you know schedule a meeting with our
expert to explain what i just explained
if you have not um if you don't if you
don't know and if you will if you're
willing to if you want to learn more
from one of our uh
representatives so this is the form and
now let's go on the top
so what kind of research there was a
question uh on the chat
that was addressed by um
dr raghavendran from
and the question was
that
the question was
uh data analysis can in cancer research
so you will get answers to those
questions here like not all the answers
but obviously we have put together on
briefly that what areas this different
data analysis tools could be applied to
so we have infectious diseases you can
learn about this different type of
analysis that students usually do but
you can also read a research paper and
let us know that okay can we do this can
we do this these are bioinformatics data
science analysis can we do this yes and
we will be able to help you out so these
are some of those areas but not all of
the areas because that is impossible
every day new research is going on but
we have listed some of them out so that
you get an idea that what could be done
in infectious disease research what
could be done in oncology research and
there are project examples i already
told you that what could be done in
oncology research what could be done in
you know precision medicine research
what could be done in agricultural
research what could be done neuroscience
metabolic disorder space omex and here
you will find a lot more examples that
you saw right it has all the like a lot
of projects that students have completed
published and all of that so from cystic
fibrosis
uh to saskov to to you know
cancer
long non-coding rnas as therapeutic
targets for cll
biomarkers prostate cancer
cervical cancer
brain metastasis
glioblastoma
you will see multiple sclerosis
again
glioblastoma so these are different
project examples you know that you
can see for yourself in this webpage
and decide like maybe this is the area
that you would want to work maybe not
but you will get an idea that what
people have been able to achieve
from this sort of you know
training and research so it's just not
training it is training plus research so
obviously that requires some dedication
so it will not happen automatically we
will be asking you to do complete things
on time do reporting and it's a guided
way of doing things but it obviously is
going to help you out
to do this in a shorter period of time
which is one of the biggest key
advantages
some of the things that we also do is to
bring
top
researchers from around the world and
you can find that out you i'm not just
saying this because you can see these
videos
and you can see that these
researchers from top universities what
is they what is they what what are the
research that they are doing
and how you can also like someday as you
work on your research proposal could
even work with them or could you know do
similar kind of research
so this is the form to fill up and then
you go to this entire process so i hope
that i've been able to clarify the
entire research process it was a long
presentation and demonstration i hope
that clarifies your doubts and uh
starting january starting february we'll
be starting
this entire research fellowship program
for new students so i'll welcome
all who would be joining us and start
this exciting journey with us uh to work
on research projects so uh now we'll be
open to research um that it will be open
to questions
and if you have any questions you feel
free to unmute yourself
or you can feel free to write it in the
chat or we can read some of your entries
and
and
help you understand
so please let us know what what what is
that
question that you have
so there is a question
here
so he's asking that would there be
opportunity to interact with faculty one
on one so we will have a lot of mentors
who will be helping you with uh your
project
and we have a
communication groups we utilize we are a
bioinformatics company but we are also a
company who utilizes
all the latest modern technologies so
not just um this tower platform but all
the social media platforms
we are available on skype telegram
whatsapp you name it and uh there's a
direct interaction so
you will be able to communicate with us
and if you are genuinely working we will
be able to help you out no worries about
that
and uh bupinder again asks if the afghan
other institution institut can other
institutions students also eligible for
emergency research project
um i would say that would be difficult
to accommodate because we are hoping
that students from mit
because they would be reporting to their
faculty that would be more convenient
for him for them but yeah we will have a
lot lot more research we already have a
lot lot more research projects that one
could one could join but that would
require you to first
show that you were you are capable of
working on those research projects by
completing
the coursework
and
if you are
if you're in
if you're ready for that we can
also
think and maybe accommodate you to some
of those research projects vishal saying
i have some same doubt okay yeah i think
that clarifies is this for mit
university students only no it is not it
is for everyone
who as i said it is for everyone it is
not just for mit students but mit
students uh we have a mou with mit
university and
with that mou we are providing them with
additional scholarships and
faculty guided research projects but if
you're an expert and if you if you
become if you show that you have reached
10 000 points and you know about these
technologies and you know you've worked
through some of the research examples
project examples then sure we can we can
we'll be able to guide you to the
research project that interests you the
most
ship
asking is there an opportunity to work
on space medicine
space medicine that's quite interesting
with respect to precision medicine as to
what kind of medicine to prescribe yeah
that's a great great question
so yes we are getting that information
and how do you do precision medicine
focus space uh
for astronauts yes i mean that's
because they're exposed to high level of
radiation so there are changes that are
happening so minimizing that and giving
them proper help is something
that is our responsibility people who
are living on earth they should be able
to help people who are who are going to
uh beyond earth to do this exploratory
uh
you know exploration because they are
living in a very hostile condition so
our job and that's why
nasa gene lab and all the research is
coming in is just to help in that so yes
i think that is one of the key things
that one would be doing
i'm a phd student you need advice in my
work how can you help me so if you're a
phd student um that is uh then you are
doing a research then you have might
have a research proposal
and uh you can utilize the resources
that i just discussed during this call
and then we can help you similar way but
the way we are helping everyone so
you can be more specific ziad
that
what is that word what kind of help do
you want
so yes i mean if it is related to
research if it is related to
bioinformatics if it is related to data
science we will be able to help you
yes uh solomon is this fellowship also
for international students yeah actually
we already have a big group in nigeria
and
we have many programs ongoing and many
nigerians have um
have done this research fellowship with
ourselves many are doing right now and
i think nigeria is a is a great country
where
student researchers are very
enthusiastic
and
we have a lot of students from there and
also a team there local team
can we finalize the project with mentors
one-on-one
yeah initially you would have to
go through the coursework and learn
about
the different
technologies and different type of you
know
analysis
and then once you have a very specific
research question
then the mentors will are going to work
help you one-on-one before that we have
obviously there is a one-on-one group on
skype um where you can discuss that and
then schedule a meeting if it is a
research question then yes we
accommodate there's the meeting link
that you can schedule meeting with a
mentor when they are available so yes
obviously you can do that as also
yeah sakshi i understand that you are
interested okay you're interested in
neuroscience but not sure where to start
with that's where we have all the
coursework put together we have projects
on neural we are already doing a group
project
on alzheimer's so there's a lot of
opportunity that you can start exploring
with the research fellowship so research
is an ongoing process so i would say
that you need to start and once you
start you will find your ways because
that's how we all have learned because
we started and then we
kind of
find out and we are all capable of doing
that we just have to
start and there is there are mentors to
guide you all guide you
that many of us did not get so it took a
lot of time so we want to we want to
minimize the time because time is very
valuable and
we appreciate that we if we can do it in
a shorter period of time with all the
guidance and the coursework and the
tools that our platform that actually
simplifies all of this and then you can
this is not like it is not fully
dependent but it is give to give you the
logic of under of analysis and then you
can do it uh
through any tools tool that you want
later in your career so it's not to make
you dependent but make you aware of what
how to do it and
how to do it in a short period of time
and
come up with really meaningful research
not just you know any research
no it is not fully funded solomon
because we already have we can give you
scholarships we can make it uh
affordable for you but it is not fully
funded because there are so many
resources if i just count them out it
would be like 500 to 1000 for per
project but what we are doing is really
really like giving the
maximum that we could frankly speaking
usually i don't say that but i'm saying
this out loud because we are
trying our best to make it available for
all of you but it cannot be free because
a lot of time all these resources all
the people who are here in our company
they are also working really hard to
make it possible for you
yeah i mean we will reach out to you
solomon if you have filled out the form
um
and uh the web pages that we should we
can reach out to you so we will be
starting
for february i am hoping that many of
you register before that complete your
registration we have uh miss asparshthar
here she is helping students with
registration
uh
we have also miss sunalika here she also
helps student to understand some of the
things
so
yes i mean please complete your
registrations and then reach out to us
for all of those things and we will be
able to help you
how
long does it say there is one question
from rakesh
how can we use herbal drug data analysis
in bringing up new formulation or new
drug
it's a very question but uh i'll take it
so herbal
herbal or like you know
as i said there are medicinal plants
that are being sequenced
so also metabolites from these different
plants so that information is available
now you have to use that information
and uh on the tower platform you can
find
uh if you have the three dimension or
three dimensional or two dimensional
structure which is the sdf or smiley
format you can look for similar
molecules like with the similar scaffold
or similar kind of and then through that
way you can
find new drugs
that is one way i mean we use also ai
and uh
um
deep learning that isn't an advanced
stage but yeah that
for you to start and to reach that you
have to first go through the basic
basics are very important you have to
understand that other if you don't do go
through the basic you will be getting
all those questions like that
that
is getting like that you can get answers
when you go through this basic training
and then it is a step wise process step
one is to get basic and then
intermediate and then advanced if you
jump directly to advance without doing
the basic then you will be in a will
you'll end up with questions that will
be difficult to answer
how long does
how long does it take to complete 10 000
course point in average very short time
10 000 points maybe two days or three
days maximum maybe one day if you're
like
giving a lot of time
so the point system and the course work
is very simple it is very interactive
you have to read through the coursework
not like long texts it has a video
graphics all of that so we do
face this challenge that
many students do not want to you know
read a lot and there's a video is also
there for those
so
it is best if you go through the
coursework not just once but twice
because sometimes it is it is required
so for you
if you give initially some good amount
of time to all of this i am pretty sure
you're going to do really well so giving
a good amount of time initially is going
to help you
okay are there any more questions please
feel free to put it in the chat and we
along with our team will be happy to
help you out
kirti is asking can we do drug research
by data science and ai yeah that is what
i just this entire presentation was
about that only so yes
[Music]
we are working on healthcare research
and that involves
drug research obviously finding drugs or
looking for
uh targets
and all of that and we are using data
science and ai so exactly that's what
one of the main thing that we do
zara zara is always there in our
webinars it's really nice to see you
zera uh you can
you can do through herbal effects on uh
dr
raghav can you answer that i i don't i'm
not sure if i am
if i'm getting this herbal effects on
gene expression also
yes sarah i mean you can definitely do
herbal effects on gene expression
also but although the
the issue one would encounter is
not many
excuse me not many research is actually
uh
um
interested in
taking or interested in identifying the
effects of herbal treatments or effects
of alternative medicine
are trying to characterize alternative
medicine through omix technologies so
this is an evolving field right now
one of the reason could be
alternative medicine and that includes
herbal effects are herbal treatment
could be non-specific in nature
so uh
this this non-specific nature of this
alternative medicine uh lies a somewhat
um
it doesn't agree with the very specific
intervention of allopathic medicine or
allopathic intervention so that is where
uh to what uh
the omex technologies are actually
optimized for so people are actually
doing a lot of work uh in
understanding alternative medicine and
their effects on different systems so
uh so we can find some
[Music]
data on that also but
yeah it is it is still an ongoing
research so you will find
all the challenges that is
that is associated with trying to find
data sets and trying to understand the
effects and trying to um
trying to uh
quantify the methods for the ongoing
research uh area so it is it is as i
mentioned there's still a lot
developing i mean there's still the
developing field now
oh can okay let's take another query i
hope that answers your question sarah
so
if one finds an expression data gene
expression data set that studies uh
herbal effects or alternative medicine
with respect to a normal
with respect to untreated version with
respect to control then
we can conclude or we can identify
the effect of herbal through gene
expression levels also so there is
nothing stopping us from doing that sort
of analysis
so um
can let's hope that answers your
question let's take another one sakshi
asks
can machine learning be used to find
antiviral properties
of vanillin flavor what is vanillin
flavor
um
i have to find out
so if it's a
yeah i have to find out what is well in
vanillin flavor this looks like
extremely specific query
let's quickly do a
vanillin structure
okay so aldehyde it's okay
okay it is also uh looks like this is
also an alternative uh medicine kind of
it's an organic compound with
um
mostly aldehydes and hydroxyls
uh this is a primary extract of vanilla
bean
so okay this is okay this is behind the
vanilla food that's interesting now
um
i mean
first the antiviral properties of
vanillin flavor has to be established by
proper biological methods right i mean
by experimental biological methods so
machine learning cannot substitute for
experimental biological methods so when
we have data i mean i will tell you what
machine learning can do so let's say
that somebody
somebody is extremely interested in
identifying the antiviral properties of
an alien flavor so they they takes the
molecule they take the molecule and then
studies its antiviral properties or its
intervention properties across several
viral interventions
pathogens and then they tabulate or they
they record the data and then when we
have the data or when one has such data
one can study how this structure can
influence or can have antiviral
properties for selected hosts or
selected virus
those then one can use this data to
predict whether this vanillin flavor or
this structure can be effective against
certain virus or not effective against
certain virus so conversely if one can
identify such antiviral properties of a
chemical structure so as dr mohit
actually just mentioned one can generate
similar structures for this chemical
structure and then maybe from this
structural properties one can postulate
or one can identify whether machine
learning can interpret these structural
characteristics to identify similar
leads or similar hits that might have ah
or that could give us a good
a short list of um
compounds that look like vanilla vanilla
or vanilla compound wellington flavored
compound that might have antiviral
properties so without the underlying
data machine learning cannot generate
data it's a data science method so for
that to be effective we need solid data
so when we have solid data then we can
get creative
in applying different machine learning
techniques to
maximize the potential of these machine
learning algorithms to extract all
possible information from the data that
we might have
that might be hidden under the
distribution data distribution so that
one can do so hope that answers your
queries actually so when we have do we
have any other queries okay
and that is a comment from yakshit
bonsal
experimental research takes a lot more
time in comparison to computational
research so how is it possible to keep
up with the dry and wet lab results when
the next steps are indeed interdependent
or reach okay
lot more time in comparison to yes that
is correct how is it possible to keep up
with the dry
and wet lab results when the next steps
are interdependent on each other
i mean when you have data when you have
wet lab data so what you are in silico
approach or what dry lab data can do is
it can narrow down your focus it can
give a confirmation of or it can give a
confirmation that ah across
species or across
a variety of different dimensions that
you might not be able to test or check
for
wet lab results so if your wet lab
results are mostly this is how it is
biological bench experiments are
extremely focused
for the system
for the assay and for the analysis and
for the measurement so
when one does such an experiment then
one can
see whether this can be generalized
whether this application whether this
finding can be generalized first across
the system if that is possible to across
the several effects that one study so
that is what it can do
so by doing this it can provide you
very uh
valuable clue and informations on how
your next step of
designing your experiments can can be uh
yeah how you can design your next step
of experiments using such methods or
such uh yeah methods and also it can
provide you as i mentioned a hint
towards a generalization of your
effect that you study using specific
system or specific methods or
experimental techniques that are
specifically optimized for the
system and
organisms or other
variables that that you currently
consider
so when i hope that answers your query
partly at least
do we have any other questions
keep going
this is excellent yeah this is excellent
session
so keep going so that is what we will
learn in in this research internship or
research fellowship program so first you
will ask dr mohit has
wonderfully explained in his
presentation
you will learn the logic behind why we
are doing such an analysis so that is
that to me is very very important so
once you understand the logic and uh
performing such an analysis in talbot
bioinfo platform can easily translate
into coding free or
[Music]
biobioinformatics without coding so
that actually takes the priority in my
view um
because
if you understand the logic and all of
us are a
biologist and
all of us are research researchers to
some extent and we would not have come
this far without having logic behind our
analysis or behind our understanding
methods so
we have to apply the same logic in
bioinformatics analysis also so
understand the logic behind applying
several different methods and
the choice of the method
and
choice of the data and how these two
translate into fine-tuning your research
questions and how you can maybe collect
more data or maybe subset the data that
you already have to
specifically answer and explore your
questions so such
logic based methods
are
extremely helpful for you when you
extend your understanding of these
analysis not only to current research
project but for your career as well so
when you encounter such situation in
future then you will quickly uh
recollect the logic behind applying
several different methods and then pick
and choose the correct method and
if some of you are interested in
learning
the coding background or learning the
learning applying these methods using r
or say python then we have a extremely
friendly user-friendly
module-based system where each and every
step is
explained to you
clearly on why we are performing such uh
i mean executing this piece of code and
what it actually gives us what output
that it actually produces and
how to get to that output uh when we
provide you with
simple exercises like simple learn the
code a section where we delete part of
the syntax so that you can test yourself
how well you have grasped the
logic behind applying such
yeah methods using our coding let's say
or using python codes in
in our omics logic platform
so
any other queries
regarding this
or any other uh
general area
all right i think we're good uh dr
raghav and uh i think all of those who
have joined has gained something from
this and it was great talking to you all
interacting with you all
and uh we hope that many of you would uh
join the research fellow and become our
research fellows and we would work
together
uh with uh doing
like really interesting stuff
so i'll now pass it on to sunalika to
conclude the session and share any links
if that are necessary
um well thank you so much dr mohamed
i would like to reshare my screen just
in a way
okay so if you have any questions please
put them in the chat box so that we can
answer your questions and get you
started
okay so if you have no more questions
then i i believe we are good to end the
meeting and those who would like to get
themselves enrolled they can definitely
reach out to uh ms bashter she is our
marketing uh associate and she'll be
able to
get you enrolled in the program and in
case you would like to just go through
all of the details that we shared today
about the program structure and also
look at the recent research uh
projects by our research fellow then you
can definitely go ahead and visit the
[Music]
page here
i put the link in the chat box here you
will find all the details about the
months for which the fellowship program
on the internship program is available
also it is available for four months so
we have not
mentioned it here
so uh those who are specifically joining
from there
sorry so those who are specifically in
their final years they are supposed to
work on their dissertation project and
submit it um by me right so that comes
out to be four months and that's why i
just mentioned uh
the four months duration of the
internship program where on uh where
three months you'll be working on your
project and
the uh
the last month let's say or the last 15
days will specifically be dedicated to
your report writing part
also here on the page you will be able
to learn more about the mentors that are
a part of the research fellowship
program and you can
get your questions clarified from
and also to learn more about the project
topics that you can work on i would just
like to share
the landing page for the very same as
well the specialization tracks that dr
mohith explained very well today to us
to learn more about those specialization
tracks and the type of data analysis
that is possible to work in these
specialization tracks you can find the
details on this page here
i'll put the link in the chat box for
you all
okay so talking about these
specialization tracks you will be able
to see the types of uh
data analysis or let's say the areas of
analysis possible to learn from in there
and then you'll also learn about the
example projects that we have already
for a specialized field on the arms
logic learn portal that you can go
through and get some insights after
learning about the particular type of
data analysis and understand how the
skill set that you will be learning
first could be applied to answer a real
life research problem
so this is the page page that you can
refer to understand what type of
projects you can work on and also uh
here towards the end we have
mentioned and also hyperlink all of
these research projects by our
previous research fellows and we have
also had
our research fellows from amity
university noida some of them from uh
were from also the south india uh
and also we had uh have uh research
fellows from various parts of the uh
world so including united states united
kingdom dubai and turkey as well so you
will be able to explore the projects
that we have worked upon here on the
page and also you can
look at the projects that are submitted
on the portal
just to have an idea of how this
particular process will work for you as
well and you can anytime reach out to us
on marketing at the rate
omixlogic.com
or
call us on our company's number
i'll also put the number for you all in
the chat box
it is nine eight
seven six one
three four one two zero
thank you so much swash for putting it
up
so
if we have no more questions i believe
we are good to end today's session
and we'll be looking forward to working
with you all on your research project
and have it up here on the portal
thank you everyone for joining have a
nice day and a safer one as well
you